I now want to turn my attention
from all of the
craziness that's happening in
Europe and go halfway around
the world to one of France's
colonies in the Caribbean, and
that's Saint-Domingue.
And I know I'm butchering all
of the pronunciations.
But Saint-Domingue, and its
modern name is Haiti, is the
western half of the island of
Hispaniola, which was the
island that Columbus first
stumbled upon when he
discovered the New World.
The eastern half of the island,
that you don't see
here-- I've zoomed in
on the western half.
The eastern half is now called
the Dominican Republic.
At that time it was called Santo
Domingo and it was in
the control of Spain.
Let me write that down.
So Spain is here.
You probably don't see
my yellow that well.
And then on this side, France
has colonized-- let me write
Spain bolder.
There you go.
Spain had colonized the eastern
half of the island,
France had colonized
the western half.
And just to get us up to speed
on the history, in 1492,
Columbus showed up and it
was a Spanish colony.
And I'm talking about just
the western side.
The eastern side continued
to be a Spanish colony.
But in 1697, it was officially
given over to the French, but
it was a Spanish colony
until then.
And then 1697 until the period
that we're talking about right
now, which is the late 1700s,
the period of the French
Revolution, it was
a French colony.
It's a French colony.
Now you're probably saying, Sal,
all of this craziness is
happening in France.
Kings are getting toppled,
people are getting
guillotined.
There's wars with all
of the empires.
Why are you going all the way to
this side of the world and
focusing on this small
little island?
Well, the big answer, or I
guess the main answer,
especially from the perspective
of the French--
there's other historical
reasons why
this, I think, is relevant.
But the major reason is that
Saint-Domingue at this time
was the most-- let me write
that in-- profitable slave
colony in the world.
Now these colonialists, they
cared about profit pretty much
all the time.
To a large degree, at this point
in history, that's all
they cared about.
But you have to think
about it.
Remember, what precipitated
the French Revolution-- or
what I think was a major
factor-- was
that France was broke.
So you have this little
island here.
It's a slave colony.
Their plantations produce tons
of sugarcane, hugely
profitable business.
Anything that goes on in
Saint-Domingue will matter to
France because France
is broke.
And not only are they broke,
but they have all of these
wars with pretty much
everybody in Europe.
So let's go back and remind
ourselves what was actually
happening in France
at the time.
We'll actually go
back to France.
So 1789, you had your
Convocation of the
Estates-General.
The Third Estate, they were a
little peeved, so they met at
the tennis court, they declared
themselves the
National Assembly, they had
the Tennis Court Oath.
Actually, they declared
themselves the National
Assembly, then they were
kicked out of the room.
And then they had to do the
Tennis Court Oath, where they
promised that they would
create a constitution.
And they started talking about
liberty and fraternity and
brotherhood and all men are
created equal, all of these
great ideas of the
Enlightenment.
And while all that was
happening, you had this
businessman, Vincent Oge.
I don't know if I'm pronouncing
it right.
He was a wealthy, mixed-race--
so let me write that down.
He was a mixed-race and he was
1/4 African descent and he was
3/4 European, or
French descent.
And he was in Paris
on business.
And while he was there, the
French Revolution and this
Convocation of the
Estates-General started
happening, and he said,
gee, you know what?
I'm a wealthy, educated guy.
I own land in what is now Haiti,
but in Saint-Domingue
at the time.
He actually owned slaves.
I want to be very clear
about this.
He owned slaves as well.
And he's like, I am just as good
as all of these, I guess
you could say, purely European
guys all around me, but I
don't get equal rights now.
But all of this great stuff is
happening, with talks of a new
constitution.
Let me get in on this.
And so he started lobbying with
several other, I guess
you could say, forward-thinking
individuals.
He started lobbying
for equal rights.
He lobbied for equal rights, the
rights to vote and not to
be treated like a second-class
citizen.
Now at first, they were
kind of ignored.
The National Assembly, they
wanted to do good things, but
they didn't want to do something
so extreme as
considering this wealthy,
educated, probably well-spoken
individual an equal, so they
were rebuffed a bit.
But eventually, in March of
1790, the National Assembly
passed an amendment that had the
wording, all proprietors
ought to be-- and there's some
other stuff in between--
active citizens.
Well, Mr. Vincent Oge and his
collaborators say, hey, this
is our victory.
This is the wording that tells
us, look, anyone who is a
proprieter-- I own land, I'm a
proprieter-- it says we ought
to be active citizens.
This gives us the
right to vote.
So he declared that a victory
for his rights, or people like
his rights.
And so he goes back to
Saint-Domingue and tells the
governor, look, all of this
craziness has been happening
in France, we have a National
Assembly, and they've
essentially given me
the right to vote.
Unfortunately, the governor of
Saint-Domingue ignores him, or
essentially doesn't listen to
him-- ignores what he has to
say, and says, I don't care
what's going on in France.
I'm not going to give you
and people like you
the right to vote.
So this obviously did not make
him a happy individual.
He seems like he has everything
going in his favor.
Even the national assembly
seems to be going in his
favor, but the governor
ignores him.
So he starts a revolt
when he returns, and
he's essentially rebuffed.
He returned in October of 1790,
ignored by the governor,
so he starts a revolt.
Unfortunately, his revolt
wasn't successful.
And I want to be very clear.
When he revolted, he wasn't
revolting to abolish slavery,
he wasn't revolting to give all
black men on the island
the right to vote.
He was revolting to give freemen
of color who owned
land the right to vote, and that
was probably his mistake
in the revolt.
I want to give you a little
sense of the demographics of
Saint-Domingue at that time.
There were 500,000 slaves of
African descent, you had
40,000 white colonialists, and
you had 28,000 mixed-race,
freemen of color, or however
you want to describe them.
If you're starting revolt to
defend only your rights,
you're going to get some subset
of this 28,000 against
a very well-armed,
in power, 40,000.
Now, if he had thought maybe I
should speak in a little bit
broader terms-- he was
essentially trying to become a
part of this club, but if he had
spoken in slightly broader
terms, maybe he could have
tapped into some of the angst
of that 500,000.
But he didn't, and so his revolt
was unsuccessful and he
was captured.
And then in February 1791,
he was executed.
So it seems like all
was for naught.
He went through all this trouble
to get some freedom.
He was ignored, tried
a revolt, his revolt
wasn't done that well.
He was executed, but it started
to simmer within the
consciousness of the people of
African descent at that time.
And whether or not his revolt
directly lead to what is going
to happen over the next few
years is unclear, but it did
happen and at least he was the
first one that really did try
to start a revolt
in a major way.
But anyway, after he was
executed, there started to be
a little bit more murmurrings,
especially in the North.
Most of the sugar plantations
were focused around the North,
and obviously, the more
plantations, the more profit.
And there was actually a voodoo
ceremony that was run
by an individual whose name
was Dutty Boukman.
And I looked for pictures
of him.
I couldn't find any.
Unfortunately, there aren't.
He ran this voodoo ceremony
where he essentially
instigated a slave uprising in
Haiti, or what is now Haiti,
but in Saint-Domingue.
Remember, look at those
demographics.
As you could imagine, if the
slaves themselves were to rise
up against everyone else on
the island, you could
imagine-- even though they might
not be as well organized
or as well equipped as the other
members-- just by sheer
force, they should probably
do pretty good.
And so in 1791, in August
1791, an all-out slave
rebellion begins.
Now you can imagine,
this scares France.
Putting aside all of the things
of the Revolution and
all these new notions from the
Enlightenment, here is your
most profitable colony in the
world, and all of a sudden
there's a revolt.
People on both sides of the
equation are getting
slaughtered, plantations
are getting burned.
From the new government in
France's point of view, that's
just going to hurt their
own profitability.
This is at a time, remember,
France is broke.
They're at wars with
other countries.
So France sends a delegation,
headed by
this guy right there.
His name was-- and I know
I'm butchering the
pronunciations-- Sonthonax.
I don't know the best
way to pronounce it.
And it was him plus 6,000
or 7,000 troops.
And they essentially were sent
from France to put down the
slave rebellion, to kind
of get things back to
the way they were.
And in order to kind of
consolidate everyone on
France's side right here, France
in April 1792-- so let
me write this down.
The Legislative Assembly, you
might remember, a new
constitution was created at
the end of 1791, and that
entailed a new Legislative
Assembly.
They essentially gave full
citizenship to all
free people of color.
So unfortunately, Vincent
Oge was a little bit
ahead of his time.
If he had just waited a
couple of years, he
wouldn't have had to revolt.
Or maybe he helped to
precipitate this.
So it's not clear.
Maybe his revolt, which maybe
helped precipitate the
eventual slave revolt, which
eventually might have helped
the Legislative Assembly come
to terms with this idea.
Maybe he made it happen or maybe
it would have happened
on its own, but they made
full citizens out of
free people of color.
And they probably did that-- you
could view it kind of in a
positive or a negative spin.
The positive spin was this is
consistent with the ideas of
the Enlightenment and
the Revolution.
Or if you want to kind of view
a more strategizing view on
it, they probably said, hey,
there's all this craziness
going on in Haiti, if we can at
least get these people on
our side, we might be able
to properly suppress
these people over here.
And let's be clear.
Many of these mixed-race freemen
of color, they owned
slaves themselves.
So from their own self-interest,
they were
actually very similar to the
white colonialists in
Saint-Domingue at that time.
If they were a little bit more
strategic about it, it might
have been just to kind of
consolidate the power on the
free people on the island, or
the landowners on the island.
But they sent that message with
Sonthonax and 6,000 to
7,000 troops to get things
back in order.
But you might remember-- and
even that-- this made many
people very unhappy,
even on the island.
As some of those white
colonialists at that time,
they weren't the most liberal
thinking people and they
probably didn't appreciate this
idea of freemen of color
being able to have all of the
same rights as they did.
So there was obviously a lot
of antagonism against this
guy, against Sonthonax
right there.
And then you might remember that
in February 1793-- we saw
that in the previous video,
or in several videos ago--
February 1793, you start having
war with Great Britain.
And Great Britain had control
of this, right here.
That is Jamaica.
Just to be clear, in green
right here, this is
Saint-Domingue.
And right here, this
is Santo Domingo,
controlled by the Spanish.
So you had a big problem.
Here he is, Sonthonax
right there.
He's antagonized some of the
whites, he's trying to put
down a slave rebellion,
or at least get
things back to normal.
And then all of a sudden you
have the British over here,
and you have a lot of these
white colonialists that start
saying, hey, if France is going
to be like that, we're
going to side with
the British.
We're going to side with the
British or we're going to get
help from the British and we're
going to use that help
from the British to essentially
get our way back
in Saint-Domingue.
Now Sonthonax, as far as I can
tell, he was of a more liberal
persuasion in that he was
sympathetic to the plight
definitely of people of
mixed-race, and even to the
plight possibly of slaves
themselves.
But also, for strategic reasons,
he saw the writing on
the wall as well.
He said, gee, I have 500,000
slaves and we need to fend off
the British.
This is a pretty bold action.
In the history of slavery, this
is actually one of the
most significant declarations.
In 1793, in August of 1793--
it might be a reflection of
his own ideas, or it might have
just been because of the
threat from Britain-- Sonthonax
declares freedom for
all the slaves.
He wasn't saying that they would
have all of the same
rights as land owning
men, but he's
essentially abolishing slavery.
Initially, he did it just in
the North, but in September
and October, he eventually
extended it to all of the
French possessions in
Saint-Domingue.
Now you could imagine the slaves
that were revolting
this entire time, they're
a little bit
suspicious of this gentleman.
He was, it looks like, sent to
Saint-Domingue, or what is now
Haiti, to put down
the uprising.
He shows up with 6,000
or 7,000 troops.
He tries to side with
essentially the enemies of the
slaves to put down
the uprising.
And now all of a sudden, when
the British look like a bit of
a threat, he's like, hey, I'm
ending slavery by myself.
I am just declaring slavery
to be over.
And they've been tricked before
and they're saying,
this is probably some type of a
trick just to make us become
a little passive so that they
can get back at us.
And so their leaders were a
little bit suspicious of it,
but then in February of 1794,
this was ratified.
His declaration was ratified
by the French National
Convention.
And by the time word got to
the freed slaves, or the
rebelling slaves on the island--
so we're now in May
1794-- the rebel slaves'
leader-- and this is a super
important name to know--
Toussaint L'Ouverture-- he was
the leader of the rebels, and he
was a self-educated former
slave himself.
And actually he proves himself
over and over again to be one
of the best military
generals and
actually in much of history.
In May 1794, Toussaint
L'Ouverture-- I'll write his
name twice-- decides to
essentially join sides with
the French Republic, join
sides with Sonthonax.
Now once again, let's
look at the numbers.
You have Toussaint
L'Ouverture.
He is essentially the
leader of these
500,000 newly freed slaves.
This is essentially the military
of the island.
He is now the leader
So now he is essentially, you
could almost view him as the
general or the governor of the
island, of this colony.
Despite the fact that he had
very good leadership
qualities, he also
had a bit of a
megalomaniacal side for himself.
And so he actually declared
himself governor for life.
In 1801, he issues a
constitution that declares
himself governor for life.
And in his defense, this wasn't
that unusual for this
time in the world.
I mean, you look across
the Atlantic, look
with Napoleon's doing.
He takes over the French
Republic, he essentially is
declaring himself emperor
and what not for life.
And this guy says, hey, I have
the same right to do it.
I've led these people to
essentially their freedom.
They trust me.
I'll declare myself
governor for life.
And also in his defense-- and
this also speaks to him being
a step ahead of many of the
rulers at this time-- is that
he didn't have just plain old
slash and burn tactics.
He actually did enforce
a lot of
discipline amongst his troops.
And we'll see one of his
right-hand men, Dessalines-- I
know I'm pronouncing it wrong--
he was much more
savage with the people that
he was fighting against.
But Toussaint L'Ouverture was
very disciplined and when he
came to power, he actually did
not try to get revenge on the
mixed-race or on the white
plantation owners.
He realized that, hey,
you know what?
We are a new people in charge
of what is essentially a new
country-- or in his mind it's a
new country-- but let's not
try to rock too many boats.
Let's try to kind of keep our
society going in some
reasonable way so that
we don't just ruin
ourselves into oblivion.
And he also did not declare
independence from France.
So that's an important
point too.
He didn't want to completely
disjoint themselves from
France, so no independence.
He was just happy essentially
being part of the French
empire, but he himself
will be the governor.
You could imagine
on two levels,
Napoleon was not happy.
We we remember, in 1799, and
especially 1800, Napoleon
comes to power, calls himself
the First Council.
And he's not happy on
essentially two grounds.
One, there's this upstart here
declaring himself governor for
life of this island.
No one can do that
but Napoleon.
The other problem that Napoleon
had is, all of a
sudden, once you lose 500,000
slaves and they are now
freemen and you now have to pay
them maybe slightly better
wages instead of just making
them do what you want and just
extracting all the profits, the
island, the colony becomes
much, much less profitable.
So in the back of his mind, he
also wanted to reinstate
slavery and you'll see that he
does it explicitly later on.
So he sends his brother-in-law.
You need a dirty job to do, you
got to send someone you
trust. He sends his
brother-in-law Charles Leclerc
with 40,000 troops-- so Napoleon
is definitely taking
the situation seriously-- with
40,000 troops to essentially
take back the island from
Toussaint L'Ouverture.
And so you imagine there's this
huge battle that goes on
on the island of Saint-Domingue,
or the western
half of the island,
or the part that's
controlled by the French.
And eventually, they start to
get the upper advantage.
It doesn't help, the fact that
Toussaint L'Ouverture's-- some
of his closest generals or his
closest aides, when they kind
of see the writing on the wall,
when they see that this
guy-- in the next video, I'll
talk about how barbaric some
of the things this
guy did was.
But once some of Toussaint
L'Ouverture's generals started
to see the writing
on the wall, they
actually turned on him.
And one of them was-- he
actually ends up completing
the revolution, but while he
was fighting for Toussaint
L'Ouverture-- this is
Jean-Jacques Dessalines-- him
and some of the other right-hand
men to Toussaint
L'Ouverture, he actually joins
the side of Leclerc.
Leclerc is kind of making it
look like he's not trying to
reinstate slavery, he's not
trying to take citizenship
away from people of
African descent.
He makes it look like he's
only trying to take
L'Ouverture off of
his high horse.
So this guy says, OK, fine,
for the betterment of
Saint-Domingue, I'm with you.
And at that point, Toussaint
L'Ouverture is essentially in
a very tough situation.
So Leclerc says, hey, Toussaint,
let's have some
negotiations and maybe we can
figure out some way for you to
assimilate you and the people
you're leading into
essentially Napoleon's--
what is now turning
into Napoleon's empire.
So Toussaint L'Ouverture-- being
a kind of upstanding
individual who trusts people and
a man of honor-- he says,
oh, this Charles Leclerc must
be a man of honor as well.
So he meets with him to
discuss the terms of
assimilation.
Well, it turns out Charles
Leclerc was
not a man of honor.
Maybe I could draw some devil
horns on him right there.
And he, when Toussaint
L'Ouverture shows up by
himself for a very civilized
meeting, he gets some people
to arrest him, capture him, and
then send him on a boat to
France, and essentially
Toussaint L'Ouverture dies in
France in a prison.
So I'm going to leave
this video here.
It's kind of a very
sad moment.
You have freedom for the slaves
temporarily, you have
this major historic figure
Toussaint L'Ouverture leading
the slaves and trying to
establish a new government.
But then it gets violently
suppressed by Napoleon's
henchman, by Charles Leclerc,
his brother-in-law.
And I'm going to finish this
video just with a quote from
Toussaint L'Ouverture because it
kind of foreshadows what's
going to happen in
the next video.
So this is actually something
that he said on the boat to
France after being captured.
Let me make the whole
quote here.
"In overthrowing me, you have
cut down in Saint-Domingue
only the trunk of the
tree of liberty.
It will spring up again from the
roots, for they are many
and they are deep."